okay so you guys have been asking for it
for a really long time now and today
we're gonna dive deep into two-story
archicad architectural design
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about two-story
architectural design in archicad 25. if
you're brand new to this channel on this
channel we talk about architecture and
technology every single monday and soon
most likely twice a week we're going to
be ramping up these videos because this
channel is growing every single day so
thank you so much for your support today
we're specifically focusing on how we
can create two-story architectural
design very quickly very easily and the
fundamental basics of what you need to
know to be able to do any two-story
design that your heart desires once
arcade has loaded up completely the
first thing we're going to be doing is
pressing ctrl 7 to open up our story
settings because we're doing a two-story
design this is where it is absolutely
critical i'm gonna insert a story below
i'm gonna call it footings and i'm gonna
go minus 172 millimeters because that's
approximately how big a slab with a
footing is i'm going to make my next
story 2745
and then i'm going to insert a ground
ceiling story that ground ceiling story
can be anything from
200 mil to 600 mil depending on what
you're really planning on doing so in
this instance let's say we're going to
have a concrete floor with a drop
ceiling in some areas so we're probably
going to need about 200 millimeters for
that concrete floor and then we're going
to need an additional 300 millimeters
under that if we want any of our
services to be running in bulkheads
above that we want our first floor
which is again going to be
2745 and then above that we want our
first
ceiling so it doesn't really matter what
we do in the first ceiling above that
because that's just going to keep going
on on forever we just want to dictate
that as a number above our actual
existing first floor i'll also type in
ground floor so it stays relatively
consistent now personally i like to
untick all of those on the side for
elevations we're not going to get into
that today but it's just something i
enjoy to do next we're going to click ok
and as you can see we have our footings
ground floor ground ceiling first floor
all appearing right here now let's start
by going to our ground floor double
clicking on that layer nothing's going
to happen because we have nothing drawn
we're going to make it a very simple
tutorial we're not going to go into too
much architectural design i'm going to
make it relatively nice but we're not
going to spend all day on internal fit
outs room layouts and all that let's
start by selecting our wall tool next we
want to make sure we're on our wall
external layer we have our geometric
method shaped continuous line selected
if you don't press and hold and you can
change what sort of shapes you're using
and need
next i'm going to come across to my wall
structure click all the way down
and define my stud partition i'm going
to make this the timber frame house so
90 ml stud partitions perfect so to
start drawing the first bit of a house
we click once i'm going to hold shift to
draw a perfectly dead straight line and
then press the d button to be able to
activate my distance measurement i'm
going to type in 4000 for 4 meters
click enter go back down again shift d
let's go out two meters
again shift z and let's go out six
meters on this side here
finally i'm just going to drag it back i
don't know shift d 15 meters
again holding shift aligning it with the
edge of our house clicking okay and
clicking on the mouse again we've never
used arcade before if we go into show
all in 3d at the top you'll see that
automatically our walls have been
created in 3d and we're already starting
to build something out of absolutely
nothing now to make your life a hell of
a lot easier in the future if we click
once select all of it and then press
command t what i want to do here is go
to my first floor home story and make
sure that's zero not 500 so our ground
floor walls go all the way from the base
of our slab all the way up
past the slab of the first floor so we
don't have to do additional cladding for
absolutely no reason for now that's all
we have to do we're just going to press
ok
as you can see those walls jumped up
straight away that extra 500 millimeters
and if we were to go back into command 7
to open up our story settings and change
our ground ceiling to 5 meters for
whatever reason if we clicked okay they
would automatically jump up as well so
the best thing about that is coming back
in changing that back to 500 they drop
back down if your construction method
changes if your ceiling levels change if
anything changes you don't have to go in
checking every single wall one by one to
make sure they're aligned to the correct
new slab height now we're going to come
back into our ground ceiling so we're
double clicking on ground ceiling right
clicking on our ground floor and going
show as trace reference so we can see
our ground floor below what we're going
to do here is come into our slab tool
and we're going to change our slab to
something a little bit different so as
you can see here we have some pre-made
concrete and timber floor slab finishes
i'm just gonna go with this 250
millimeter concrete slab finish go
command t it's a little bit bigger than
what we originally anticipated but
that's okay
next we're just going to simply draw
inside of our wall settings here so now
if we come back into our 3d option we'll
see that that floor is sitting perfectly
in line with these walls now from an
actual construction point of view the
wall will actually sit underneath the
floor and then the next wall will sit on
top of the floor so there will be a
discontinuation
like this that you can actually see but
for architectural visual purposes i
personally extend the walls all the way
up so we don't have to change the sides
of our slab later on we detail that in
section completely differently but
that's a whole other tutorial now let's
go back to our ground floor i'm thinking
i'm going to make this a little bit
different so just to show you guys some
additional information if we click on
all our walls they're going to be joined
like they're grouped so what we need to
do is actually press alt and
g to ungroup them and then once we click
it again you can see it's just one item
selected rather than all the walls
next we can press control or command d
to be able to actually move that object
run it all the way across this other
wall and let's say that's going to be a
bedroom instead of a main living so it
will reduce that to three metres from
that wall to that wall and by simply
pressing the minus button at the end
it'll automatically do the maths for you
now if we click escape and i hold the
control button our little scissors tool
appears and i can click on that wall to
cut it back in line with where i already
moved the second wall additionally i
want to join these two walls so if i
click once click twice these two walls
will be highlighted i can press command
or control i and it will automatically
intersect or join those two walls as you
can see that trace reference is still on
below so it's showing us what it was
before so if i just pan across and zoom
it'll disappear completely or we can
come up to here and just untick our
trace reference so we're not confused by
the same information being delayed and
lagging now that we have our base floor
pretty much done let's press our alt
button again select one of these walls
so we're copying the settings across
come up to our first floor and that we
can see that we have our ground floor
trace reference still on i'm going to
draw
a simple box by simply clicking around
on top and above of that
story below
and then i'm going to come back into my
3d option and see what's going on so as
you can see there's a few things that
are wrong in this 3d scenario first of
all this floor slab we haven't adjusted
to our new walls so we can do that in 3d
by simply clicking on this
slab clicking on the blue line coming
across to offset edge and running it all
the way back in line to the edge of our
wall and we want to make sure that we're
on the inside so it's the same as
everything else
next i'm going to click on the first
floor walls i'm going to go again alt g
so it groups those items again so i
don't have to go through and click each
wall individually
command or control t to open up the
settings i'm going to do a whole command
palette in this video underneath my
floating head here because you guys have
been requesting and asking what are the
commands so i'm just really trying to
improve these videos to make it as easy
for you guys to follow along so i hope
you do appreciate the effort that goes
in to making all these commands watching
this video over and over again to make
sure that all the commands are put in
properly anyway back to this we want to
change our not linked top story
whatsoever we just want to make that 2
seven four five and press ok
so our walls drop back down quick little
interlude as always there is some great
links down in the description below guys
if you want to check them out as a
specific example there is some
construction checklists in my digital
download section of my website you'll
find them extremely useful especially if
you're a student or an architect
starting out in practice they are
fundamental for being able to send out
drawings confident knowing that
everything that was meant to be on that
drawing has been put on it so if you are
somebody that is starting out in
architecture make sure you check out the
links there is a whole bunch of great
content down there including a discord
group chat where architect students and
all sorts of professionals from around
the world are joining every single day
and helping each other grow now
obviously we can have a roof on this
house and it could be a variety of
different options we could go for a
hampton style we could go for a modern
style we can do a million and one
different architectural styles i did
make a video talking about different
architectural elevations in a very
simple quick method so i'll link that
above as well if you want to check that
out after
today i'm just going to focus on a
little bit of architectural elements
probably a concrete roof keeping it very
slim keeping it very minimal and elegant
so to be able to create that let's start
by going to our ground floor and i'm
basically going to create a wrap around
floating roof effect now the easiest way
to create this is simply by copying this
wall across dragging it out to the edge
and we're going to make this 250
millimeters thick because that is how
thick our floor is above next i'm going
to press ctrl or command and the up
button to move one story up so as you
can see in this palette here if i go
back to down it'll go to ground floor
one up ground ceiling two up first floor
so we'll come back to our ground ceiling
now i'm going to copy this slab across
and instead of stopping in front of the
wall i'm actually going to come all the
way out in this instance to create some
sort of balcony here and then drop back
down i do want to extend that about 500
millimeters past as well so the same way
as we did in 3d click on that line
offset edge start typing in 500 and then
command down i'm also going to bring
this back out another 500 by simply
following the same steps we did before
which was command d and then pressing
the d button to type in 500 and finally
to bring these back in line with this
wall i'm going to ungroup them alt g
clicking our move node and simply
holding the shift button click once drag
back
in line what i'm going to do now is
highlight this bottom blade wall go
command c
up up
and command v or control v depending on
what system you're on
select that control d to be able to move
it drag it all the way across
and click it on this side so now if we
come back into our 3d we'll see that
we're starting to create this wrap
around roof looking blade wall
what i have done incorrectly is i
haven't gone all the way across so i'll
click on that section there
and i want this to be pure concrete so
if we open up the slab settings by
pressing command t changing it to a
structure basic composition and then
changing this to just pure concrete
clicking okay we lose that timber on top
we can get rid of that floor over there
by dragging it back so we have a
concrete concrete concrete wall now to
finish off this design we're going to
come up to our first floor ceiling press
control down down twice tap the alt key
select our new created slab control up
up
and right click to show us trace
reference for our first floor
now i'm simply just going to drag a box
potentially seven meters
to the left
run that all the way to the back of our
house so we have a feature blade wall
run it all the way back and finish it
there now if we come into our 3d we'll
see that our house is starting to take
form i don't really like that that's way
too high up i'm going to drop the bottom
of that to 2745
and i'm also going to drop
the height of this wall to the underside
of that slab so as you can see now we're
creating this wraparound ceiling effect
that we can hide our roof behind here as
well so if we come back to our first
ceiling we're going to see that we have
our roof hidden here i'm going to hold
the alt button on my trace reference
which allows me to actually use that
wall below and i'm going to draw a small
little box basically on top of that wall
that is on the first floor alt g command
t
opens up our story settings i only want
that to be about 600 millimeters high so
i can hide a roof under it now to create
our roof i'm going to go to our roof
tool and you always want to start with
your pitching point at the lowest point
which means coming over to this side of
the wall starting on the inside of this
leaf and clicking on
the actual inside coming all the way
across drawing our roof and then most
likely extending that another 110 mil
back
now it's created a very very big roof
that doesn't need to be at that angle
let's just go one degree a secret roof
we can also delete that last little bit
of that 600 millimeter upstand
so now if we look at this house from the
front from the street you don't see the
roof it's hidden behind a small little
600 mil upstand and we have this nice
cantilevering concrete looking facade
now instead of creating an actual roof
in this section what i'm simply going to
do is reduce that floor click on this
floor here go to our add polygon
and
then simply extend our concrete roof
across
and extend our concrete roof back
so what we'll effectively do from a
construction point of view is that will
be a concrete roof we'll do a balustrade
back there and hide that away so nobody
can access that area but that way we
don't have to ruin and spoil the simple
minimalistic design that we've created
so far to finish this off i do want to
come back into my ground floor go up one
level and select that concrete floor
then go back to my ground floor
and simply draw in our concrete slab at
the bottom
so we tie that
back in completely now it probably
doesn't need to be that long probably
can go back in to only about three
meters instead of the full size so we
have a sweeping s look that could be a
step up to a little
platform a little tree whatever we
decide to do in the elevation design now
let's focus on this actual elevation of
this 2d house first we're going to
change the materials of this blade wall
so if we open up the settings by
pressing command t
and overriding all of the model settings
to concrete let's change it to concrete
light 23 for the time being i'm gonna do
the exact same thing
for these concrete slabs clicking okay
and also the same thing
for this concrete blade wall over here
so now we have our concrete wrap around
roof and blade walls now these two walls
up here i want them to be in a nice dark
timber so let's make them a vertical
walnut and finish that off the remainder
of the house by pressing alt g i'm going
to paint all that titanium white so it's
a nice harsh contrast between the
concrete and the white render and we
have a dark wood up here as well now
let's come into our ground floor
and start adding some openings and some
elevations first i'm going to go to my
door click on my door settings up here
which you can also access by pressing
command t
i'm going to search for a nice large
pivot door so archicad has a pivot door
25 here if you've watched any of my
other videos you know that i hate this
orange line here so let's go override
pen
simply making them black overriding both
the pen type settings and let's make
this door
about 1800 wide and 2 4 high so it's a
very nice large door by clicking on the
3d we can see what it looks like
personally i don't really want it to be
a glass door i do want it to be solid
and i want it to be that walnut color to
match the above of what we created
so let's drop down to our model
attributes and change this wood grain to
our walnut vertical i also want to
change the frame settings so we're going
to come down to our model attributes in
fixtures and fittings
and change that to just paint ivory
black on both sides so pressing ok i'm
going to drop my main entry right here
pivoting inside coming back to 3d we'll
see we've created a nice black pivot
frame door i'm actually going to extend
that all the way up to the underside of
the concrete so it looks really really
modern and really really sleek and then
coming back into our ground floor i'm
going to press ctrl d drag it all the
way to the edge so it creates that
formal entry space next we're going to
start putting some windows in so let's
go to our window tool window settings at
the top i'm just going to simply create
a simple simple window here
so sticking with the archicad 25 window
that's absolutely fine all i'm going to
do is change those model attributes to a
black frame so it matches what we've
created with our door
keeping the ivory clear glass that's
absolutely fine i'm going to drop that
in right there
and align it with the edge of my door
again pressing command t because i hate
that orange pen i forgot to change these
two settings here
getting rid of the orange because i
can't stand it coming back into 3d
and expanding
our window
so it's a full side light next to our
pivot door finish off this ground floor
i'm going to come back in again hold the
alt button select that window downstairs
drop it randomly in that space
control or command t to open up the
settings and let's start from the
beginning and change a few things so i
want this to be a much wider window
let's call it two one for the time being
and we'll adjust the height in 3d i then
want to change the actual style of this
window so we're just going to come
across to the hv grid sash let's call it
three by three so it creates a nice grid
pattern black frames and we're going to
drop that in right there
back to our 3d we can see that we have
that extra slab so it doesn't need to be
that size but i do want to extend it the
whole width of this concrete slab here
so now we have a large black window here
we have one large window next to our
door which i'm gonna copy simply two
identical windows
on this front bedroom
coming back to 3d we have two very large
windows at the front finally coming up
to our first floor i'm going to go back
into my window settings and find a
sliding door so let's type in sliding
i'm going to use this sliding door xo
here which is a little bit wider than
usual simply changing those model
settings again so we have a black frame
all the way around pressing okay and
dropping that window in here
again forgot about those
orange lines so let's just dive quickly
back into that
get rid of those orange lines so we
don't have to deal with the ugliness of
that and in 3d we can see that is
terribly unproportionate and just so we
can see the timber on both sides i'm
going to drag that back
400mm from here and i'm also going to
drag that back in 400mm from there and
then in 3d we have a wraparound timber
we have a black frame we have a concrete
house and we basically have our
two-story architectural home in arcad 25
done in a matter of minutes anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the tutorial i hope you learned
something today if you did make sure you
smash that like button down below it
helps with the youtube algorithm and
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for more content like this if you have
any comments questions concerns or
anything in between please feel free to
leave a comment down below i do reply to
absolutely everybody as often as i can
but like i already said that's all for
me today so like always i'll see you
next monday